чим займається ірмак чим займаються ці
58 порадників вони знущаються з нас
елементарну найпростішу роботу в світі
вони виконати не можуть Я вимагаю щоб
негайно це було зроблено щоб
розблокований був цей закон а оцих цих
радників порадників треба взяти і дати
їм копняка і першому рмаку отцей закон
має бути копняка єрмаку за те як він
організував роботу Друзі Ну все в очі
сказав що я думаю ви чули рмак Іди геть
ти не можеш організувати елементарну
роботу Я вже мовчу про там корупцію все
інше і буду далі добиватися щоби те що
стосується військових страховиків
курсантів поранених інструкторів все
було виконано і щодо інших категорій теж
друзі працюю далі на вас